plus de soixante-dix mille réfugiés ont
déjà été accueillis en russie selon les
autorités ils transitent par cette ville
de taganrog où je me trouve à 70 km de
la frontière entre la russie et ses
républiques séparatistes de données est
et de longues entre certains ont fui la
reprise des combats sur la ligne de
front tous ont en commun le fait de
blâmer l'ukraine pour cette reprise des
violences et il redoute une attaque du
gouvernement ukrainien il voit la russie
et vladimir poutine comme leur seul
moyen de salut écoutez notre espace à la
russie nous sauve je prie dieu et que
grâce à vladimir poutine les choses se
calment qu'il y ait une solution et que
la paix revienne sur nos terres
il est notre seul espoir
jamais la russie n'a attaqué personne à
travers toute l'histoire elle n'a fait
qu'aider tout le monde
vous ne savez pas quoi faire
pour ternir l'image de la russie ces
derniers jours le regain des violences
est accompagné par un regain de
propagande avec celles des chaînes de
télévision russes et des territoires
séparatistes suivi par ces populations
ayant ressorti la rhétorique de guerre
employant les termes de génocide et de
nazis pour qualifier les ukrainiens qui
voudrait selon cette propagande lancée
un génocide contre les population
russophone d'ukraine de l'est acquise à
moscou rares sont allés gens parmi ces
populations qui croient que vladimir
poutine est responsable de la situation
pour eux les seuls responsables et ce
depuis 2014 de cette guerre de ce
conflit c'est le gouvernement ukrainien
soutenu par les états unis